[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
das Wasser ist rau Meter hohe Wellen
schlagen gegen das kleine Fischerboot
das mitten auf dem Wasser im Auge des
Sturms wird 13 der 14 Passagiere
versuchen mit aller Kraft das Boot von
Kentern abzuhalten und die Segel zu
festigen sie bangen um ihr Leben doch
ein Mann auf diesem Boot ist ruhig er
hat keine Angst es ist Jesus
die brenzlige Situation die hier gerade
beschrieben wurde ist offensichtlich
nicht echt genauer gesagt beschreibt sie
das Gemälde Christus im Sturm auf dem
See Genezareth Schöpfer dieses Gemäldes
ist einer der berühmtesten Maler der
Menschheit Rembrandt von Rain doch
dieses Meisterwerk ist weg spurlos
verschwunden gestohlen beim größten
Kunstdiebstahl der Weltgeschichte unser
Fall heute bei Tatort Deutschland
[Musik]
ich bin Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Stefan
Netzeband hallo beim Einbruch in das
Isabella Stewart gardener Museum in
Boston erbeuten Diebe im Jahr 1990
dieses unersetzbare Bild von Rembrandt
und 12 weitere Kunstwerke darunter auch
Bilder von Meistern wie vermehrt und
Manet jedes dieser gestohlenen Werke ist
unersetzlich der Wert der verschwundenen
Kunst liegt bei mehr als 500 Millionen
Dollar und bis heute stellen sich
Ermittler und Kunstliebhaber die Frage
wo sind die gestohlenen Werke und wer
waren die Täter diesen Fragen wollen wir
heute auf den Grund gehen und Mirko
dafür habe ich uns einen richtigen
Sportprofi mitgebracht okay Sportprofi
mein Name ist Walter Straten bei Bild
bin ich stellvert in der Chefredakteur
für den Sportteil und in meinem zweiten
Leben sammle ich Kunst und zwar alte
Meister ja dieser Diebstahl oder dieser
Raub aus Isabella Stuart gardener Museum
in Boston ist deshalb auch nach so
langer Zeit immer noch so bedeutend im
negativen Sinne weil nicht nur drei zehn
Kunstwerke verschwunden sind seitdem
sondern zwei super bedeutende ganz
bedeutende die auch nicht zersetzen sind
also Walter Straten Sportprofi bei Bild
und übrigens auch
tatortliebhaber also alle die wissen
wollen wie welcher Tat oder
empfehlenswert ist welche Wiederholung
mal gucken soll sind auch bei Walter
Strafen immer gut aufgehoben einen Mann
des Multitaskings und bevor wir weiter
mit Walter über die Bedeutung dieses
Raubes auf die Kunstgeschichte sprechen
werden da reisen wir erstmal gemeinsam
nach Osten zurück in dieses Jahr 1990
genauer gesagt in die Nacht zum 18 märz
[Musik]
in dieser Nacht fallen die Menschen in
der amerikanischen Großstadt den Saint
Patrick's Day die Innenstadt Bostons ist
voll von feiernden Menschen überall
finden Party statt die Bars sind voll
der Alkohol fließt in Strömen
doch im twenty five Events way ist es
ganz still hier ist man weit weg von der
Innenstadt den Saint Patrick's Partys
und Menschenmassen und hier steht das
Isabellas Stewart Gartner Museum das
dreistöckige Gebäude wirkt beinahe
unscheinbar von außen eine
klinkersteinfassade mehrere Fenster und
Schornsteine das sich hinter diesen
Mauern die größten Schätze der Kunstwelt
verbergen vermutet man auf den ersten
Blick nicht aber der Schein trügt sobald
man durch die Tür des Museums geht fühlt
man sich als sei man in einem Palast die
Räume sind riesig und pompös Kunstwerke
funkeln in jedem Zimmer in der Mitte des
Gebäudes liegt ein groß angelegter
Innenhof eigens aus Italien angelieferte
Säulen ragen hier mit Palmen um die
Wette in die Höhe ein Highlight für die
Besucher
doch in der Nacht zum 18 märz 1990 sind
keine Besucher im Isabella Stuart
gardener Museum nur die zwei Nachtwachen
befinden sich im Gebäude einer der
beiden Männer Randy hustand dreht gerade
seine Runde durch die dunklen leeren
Ausstellungsräume sein Partner Rick
aberf langweilt sich unter dem Tresen
noch um 1.24 Uhr lässt die Klingel am
mitarbeitereingang Rick Evers
hochschrecken es sind zwei Polizisten
sie tragen Uniform schnurwerte und
zeigen dem Wachmann ihre Ausweise es
gäbe eine Ruhestörung behaupten die
Einsatzkräfte und bitten um Einlass der
Wachmann Rick drückt auf den Sommer und
öffnet den Polizisten damit die Tür sind
sie hier allein fragt einer der
Polizisten nein antwortet
mein Partner dreht gerade eine Runde die
Polizisten weisen ihn an seinen Kollegen
nach unten zu rufen Rick aber sitzt
inzwischen nicht mehr sondern steht
neben dem Tresen als Randy hustons
Mitarbeiterbereich ankommt legen die
Polizisten kurzerhand den beiden Wachen
Handschellen an meine Herren das hier
ist ein Überfall verkünden die falschen
Polizisten sie zerren die Wachmänner
über die Treppe nach unten in den Keller
des Museums kleben Tape um ihre
Gesichter und befestigen die
Handschellen an einem Stromkasten die
Wachen sind bewegungsunfähig der Raubzug
kann beginnen
das Isabella Stewart gardener Museum ist
mit Bewegungsmeldern ausgestattet
deshalb können wir heute fast jeden
Schritt der Diebe nachempfinden über die
Haupttreppe laufen die Verbrecher an den
ersten Stock sie haben ein klares Ziel
das holländische Zimmer ein pompöser
Raum hier hängen die holländischen
Meister wie der Name schon sagt also
viele der wertvollsten Gemälde des
Museums die grüne Tapete geht beinahe
unter so voll sind die Wände mit
riesigen goldenen Bilderrahmen die
Verbrecher reißen zuerst rembrans
Christus im Sturm auf dem See Genezareth
und vermehrt das Konzert von der Wand
sie schlagen die Bilderrahmen auf den
Boden so dass das Schutzglas
zersplittert im Anschluss schneiden die
Verbrecher die Gemälde aus ihren Rahmen
und das ist nur der Anfang zwei weitere
rembrans werden hier gestohlen sowie
eine alte chinesisches Skulptur die
Diebe müssen sich während ihres
Raubzuges aufgeteilt haben zweimal
werden die Bewegungsmelder in einem
Zimmer am anderen Ende des Stockwerks
ausgelöst um 1 Uhr und um 2 Uhr 8 Uhr
ist einer der Diebe in der sogenannten
short Gallery und stiehlt hier sechs
weitere Kunstwerke darunter 5
Zeichnungen des Künstlers Edgar auch im
Erdgeschoss schlagen die Diebe noch
einmal zu hier klauen sie ein Gemälde
des französischen Malers Manet um 2:45
Uhr fliehen die Verbrecher vom Tatort
steigen in ein Auto und verschwinden in
der Post in der Dunkelheit okay moment
mal Stefan
2:45 Uhr verlassen die Täter den Tatort
1:24 Uhr haben sie bei Rick Airbus an
der Tür geklingelt das sind mehr als
anderthalb Stunden für einen Raub
irgendwie ziemlich viel Zeit das klingt
für mich als würden die sich sehr sicher
fühlen Mirko auf jeden Fall so viel sei
gesagt das wird nicht die einzige offene
Frage in unserem heutigen Fall bleiben
okay dann erstmal zur Bilanz dieses
Einbruchs
13 gestohlene Kunstwerke und ein Schaden
in dreistelliger Millionenhöhe der
Kunstraub sorgt weltweit für
Schlagzeilen die bild-titel damals zwei
falsche Polizisten plauten echte
rembrands das FBI übernimmt die
Ermittlungen gibt sich zu Beginn sogar
siegessicher die Kunstwerke schnell
wieder zu finden die ausgerufene
Belohnung für Hinweise ist kurz nach dem
Bruch eine Million Dollar doch ziemlich
schnell müssen die Ermittler feststellen
dass bei diesem Überfall alles ganz
anders als bei anderen Kunstraum ist und
sie den lieben nur schwer auf die
Schliche kommen Bild kunstfäden Walter
strahlten ordnet das für uns ein sie
sind völlig irrational vorgegangen sie
haben nicht nur die zwei superstücke
vermehrt und rembrand gestohlen sie
haben auch etwas wertloseres mitgenommen
und stattdessen z.B denn raubt der
Europa von Tizian auch ein absolutes
top-bild liegen lassen bzw hängen lassen
und sie haben Dinge mitgenommen gleich
zusammen passen sie haben wie gesagt
diese beiden super wertvollen Stücke
rembrand und vermehrt mitgenommen sie
haben auch noch Robert flink die garmane
so tut der Geist auch schon
höherwertiger Künstler aber flink zum
Beispiel ist ein rembrand Schüler der
jetzt nicht ganz so bedeutend ist sie
haben aber auch völlig ich würde sagen
wertlose aber doch wirklich mit den
anderen Kunstwerken bedeutungslose
Stücke mitgenommen die hatten ja
offenbar keine Einkaufsliste mit warum
haben die nicht noch ein paar mehr
wertvollere Stücke gestohlen nicht nur
die Auswahl der gestohlenen Kunstwerke
irritiert die Experten der aus dem
Erdgeschoss gestohlene Magnet im
sogenannten blauen Zimmer aber in diesem
Raum erfasste zu keinem Zeitpunkt des
Überfalls ein Bewegungssensor eine
Bewegung folgt mal dem Sensor betrat
also niemand das blaue Zimmer während
des Raums die letzte Person die den
Bewegungsmelder auslöste war Wachmann
Rick ever Stunden vor dem Überfall er
kam daraufhin tatsächlich auch
kritisiert der Ermittler die waren
sowieso davon überzeugt dass der
Einbruch einen inside job war denn dass
die Diebe mehr als 80 Minuten im Museum
waren das haben wir ja vorhin schon
erwähnt dass verwunderte nicht nur dich
Mirko auch für die Ermittler war das ein
starkes Indiz aber eine Beteiligung
konnten sie weg aber nie nachweisen bis
heute beteuert er vehement seine
Unschuld 2015 Beklagte Rick airbush
sogar in einem Interview dass er immer
noch mit dem Überfall in Verbindung
gebracht wird das hört ihn bis heute
doch Rick Ebbs wird nicht die einzige
Person auf der Verdächtigen Liste sein
dennoch inzwischen mehr als 30 Jahren
Ermittlungen wurden viele Theorien
aufgestellt und wieder verworfen noch
mal Walter Straten
na eine Theorie ist dass die IRA die
irische publikanische Armee dahinter
steckte die Logik ist dass Osten in den
USA eine Hochburg der ihren war die auch
unterstützt wurde die ihra von dort aus
und es war eine Masche der IAA in den
70er bis 90er Jahren Kunstwerke zu
stehlen und dann die Besitzer sozusagen
zu erpressen ihr Bild wieder zurück zu
kaufen das ist in Irland tatsächlich
auch passiert mit einem anderen vermehrt
das gestohlen wurde wo sich allerdings
der Besitzer geweigert hat zu zahlen und
das Bild ist zum Glück denn ich glaube
dem Schließfach wieder aufgetaucht also
ja Theorie ist eine Möglichkeit
glaubwürdige halte ich allerdings dass
es lokale Gangster aus Osten waren und
da gibt's ja auch einige Indizien für
Boston gehört wie weitere Städte und
Bundesstaaten im Nordosten der USA zum
Gebiet Neu England hier dominierte in
den 90ern die Mafia die Unterwelt kaum
ein Verbrechen wurde gegangen ohne dass
die organisierte Kriminalität ihre
Finger im Spiel hatte und Kunst Geld bei
denen als internationale Währung und als
Ticket aus dem Gefängnis Kunst war damit
also hoch im Kurs unter den Kriminellen
ein Hotspot der organisierten
Kriminalität war eine Kfz-Werkstatt in
Boston hier gingen die Gangster ein und
aus betrieben wurde die Werkstatt von
carmelonellino einem Verbrecher mit
Verbindungen zur Mafia
seine Komplizen waren unter anderem
George Rice Felder und Lenny die Museo
Reisfelder hat sich vor dem Kunstraub
offenbar verdächtig gemacht laut dem
Bostoner Radiosender double you be you
are haben er und ein Freund sich mit
anderen Gangstern über einen solchen
Einbruch unterhalten außerdem soll er
sich erkundigt haben wo man
Wertgegenstände gut verstecken könnte
das klingt in der Tat schon mal ziemlich
verdächtig und es kommt noch besser
George Rice fällt das Schwägerin und
sein Bruder behaupten beide sie hätten
das gestohlene man nähbild über
Reisfelder das Bett hängen sehen seine
Schwägerin erzählte sogar in einer
netflix-dokumentation sie habe
Reisfelder dabei geholfen ist dorthin zu
hängen und was sagen die Gangster zu dem
Vorwurf George Reisfelder und Lenny die
Museo starben beide im Jahr 1991 also
ein Jahr nach dem Überfall Reisfelder an
einer Überdosis Kokain die Museum wurde
erschossen
im Jahr 2015 behauptete das FBI sogar
sie wüssten wer das Museum überfiel die
Namen wollten sie jedoch nicht bekannt
geben denn die Täter seien bereits
verstorben okay also könnte man doch
eigentlich die Spur zu den Kunstwerken
leicht herausfinden sie endet bei
Reisfelder und die Museo eigentlich
schon aber es gibt weitere Namen die
immer wieder mit dem überfallen
Verbindung gebracht werden zum Beispiel
der Bostoner Gangster Robert guarenta
der ein guter Freund der schon genannten
Merlin war guarenta soll kurz vor seinem
Tod im Jahr 2004 einem anderen Gangster
zwei der gestohlenen Kunstwerke
geschenkt haben
bei dem Beschenkten wiederum handelte es
sich um seinen langjährigen Freund Bobby
gentile das Erzählte jedenfalls seine
Witwe den Ermittlern im Jahr 2010 zwei
Jahre später durchsuchte das FBI
daraufhin gentiles Haus und fand
interessante Dinge unter anderem eine
Polizeiuniform Handschellen und eine
Hand geschriebene Liste der gestohlenen
Kunstwerke inklusive Wert dieser auf dem
Schwarzmarkt die Liste steckte in einer
Bostoner Zeitung deren Schlagzeile
Isabella stuartner Museum ausgeraubt
also war die Spur zu Guar Rente offenbar
vielversprechender als die zum Gangster
Eisfelder aber was sagte der angeblich
Beschenkte Bobby gentile dazu
gentilash tritt bis zu seinem Tod im
Jahr 2021 seine Beteiligung am Überfall
ab die Kunstwerke habe er auch nicht
doch der Verdacht dass Robert Gor Rente
beteiligt gewesen sein muss erhärtet
sich im Februar 2022 denn sogar seine
Frau belastet ihn und behauptet Guar
Rente habe einen Mitwisser namens Jimmy
Marx 1991 erschossen okay okay okay das
ist eine ganz schön verworrende Mafia
Geschichte Mirko das muss man einfach
mal zugeben wir versuchen das mal
zusammenzufassen mehrere Gangster des
Bostoner Untergrunds behaupten
unabhängig voneinander sie wären im
Besitz der Kunstwerke einige von ihnen
sind danach tot und der höchst
merkwürdigen Umständen Reisfelder
Schwägerin und Bruder behaupten sie
hätten eins der gestohlenen Gemälde über
seinem Bett hängen sehen Gangster Boss
guarentis Ex Frau behauptet auch sie
hätte einige der Bilder gesehen und ihr
verstorbener Ehemann hätte die
Kunstwerke an seinen Freund Bobby
gegeben außerdem soll ihr Ehemann Jimmy
Marx erschossen haben nachdem er damit
prahlte die Kunstwerke zu besitzen mir
schwirrt der Kopf wer hat denn nun
wirklich die Kunstwerke was sagen denn
die Ermittler bei einer Pressekonferenz
verkündeten FBI Ermittler sie seien sich
sicher dass die Kunstwerke nach vieler
Delphia und Connecticut gebracht worden
wären doch dann verliert sich die Spur
bis heute 33 Jahre nach dem Einbruch es
gibt auch aus dem Vermächtnis von
Isabella Sword Garner der Gründerin des
Museums die Anweisung ist darf in diesem
Haus nichts verändert weder dazu gekauft
werden noch verkauft werden deswegen
hängen diese leeren Rahmen auch wie ein
Mann mal da an ihre alten Stelle und
wenn diese Bilder wieder zurückkehren
wäre das natürlich ein Traum auch weil
gerade das rembrandbild ist unersetzlich
weil das ist einzige marinebild ist von
rembrand aber wir haben so lange
gewartet ich weiß nicht ob wir noch mal
30 Jahre warten müssen falls das
eintrifft werden wir euch hier darüber
natürlich berichten wer weiß vielleicht
gibt es nach all den Jahren jemanden der
etwas weiß und sich traut zu sprechen es
würde sich jedenfalls lohnen die
Belohnung liegt inzwischen nämlich bei
10 Millionen Dollar also liebe Podcast
Hörer wer was weiß könnte sich lohnen
und damit sind wir am Ende der heutigen
Ausgabe wir danken euch fürs Zuhören wir
haben diesen Fall mit Quellen des Boston
Harold Boston Globe Bost Magazine und
double you be you are erzählt Redaktion
Stefan Netzeband und Lilly von der Osten
Schnitt und Aufnahme Stefan Netzeband
Postproduktion wie immer durch Wake
world München schön dass ihr dabei wart
und hoffentlich bis zur nächsten Ausgabe
euer Mirko und euer Stefan